gangbang is like i don't get it i don't
get it at all like it has i have no
interest
see it's weird like i'm usually not a
fan of gangbang but like
i am not a fan of when it's done well
like [ __ ] yeah
i can watch it yeah yeah i don't know
and karana did it well in my opinion
it's so
there are too many dicks here yeah
there's there's more than one dick two
men there's two minutes there's only a
certain amount of dicks i can solve in
certain yeah
i can't self-insert myself into six
digits
there's no [ __ ] situation in my mind
where i'm like i would love to be around
with five other men
well that's your problem you self-insert
yourself into every hentai you watch
right so of course you're not gonna like
a show like this
yeah because it's fantasy and it's a
gang bang
not everything i saw often said but i
think i get the most enjoyment well then
what
what's like a genre you don't solve
insert oh [ __ ]
is there any yeah i mean there's i mean
like of any hentai you watch is there
one where you're just like i can't
self-insert well there's plenty where i
like
it those are the medium ones for me
right like the best ones are the ones
where i can be like
i wish that was me i wish that was
[ __ ] me you know what i mean
you don't agree no yeah yeah i i agree
like this curry you know
isn't like my favorite hint to like but
it's just such a unique experience for
me
it's it's definitely not my favorite but
i can always go back and re-watch it
yeah
so it's a unique experience in the same
way that's [ __ ] your pants
i don't i don't do it often and i never
want to do it it's embarrassing and i
feel dirty after it it's a different
kind of
nuts like post not regret the series
yeah
either way i gave it a zero out of town
oh my god yeah
yep zero ten we just we just put in if
we put in the milk in karina then it
would have been like at least
to me is like beyond the scale in all
caps i put it's so long
please make it end i legitimately feel
sick
you'll come around to it no i will not
that's like because this is like the
meme right of like the older you get the
more [ __ ] up
needs to be when to get off yeah like i
don't want to get into this [ __ ] at like
20.
like it's only like 40. what am i going
to have to get off to like multiple
shitty gangbangs
at which point did you realize that oh
this this is going to be [ __ ] up for
the entire thing this is
the moment i saw the tags i was like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] like mind control plus gangbang
plus rape is like the the ultimate trio
of like so fulfilling prophecy
the big three the three three